I'm here sitting inside the crowded EA
play and I just happen to find a mr.
Vince Zampella here in the audience
Marie's mine what's going on Vince how
you feeling today I'm feeling great I
love this stuff
I love seeing new games I mean someone's
super excited about that men on PC right
yeah so you guys may have seen that
Vince was tweeting yesterday and there
has been a bunch of speculation so I
want to just get right to it
sure I mean we're not ready to show all
of our stuff yet we're working on a
bunch of stuff it's amazing the teams
are kicking ass but we wanted to bring a
little tidbit so we've been working with
Lucas on getting the name and kind of
the setting for what our Star Wars games
gonna be em we're gonna talk about it
right now oh you guys got any guesses I
bet you the the Internet is going wild
right now I hope so so the Star Wars
name is Jedi fallen order whoo so Star
Wars Jedi fallen order yeah so it kind
of gives you some idea that you'll be
playing a Jedi
so does that mean I get to like hold a
lightsaber yes so Vince you got it you
got anything else well it takes place
during the dark times trying to be a
little vague here but when the Jedi's
are being hunted so it's gonna be expect
Acula so far although like the hardcore
nerds out there who want to know like
where in the timeline like what between
which episodes is it between three and
four okay
I went right between three four but
sounds like a nice time you got it eh
any other tidbits it's not a nice it's a
dark time it's a dark time
bad time does that mean this could just
be all dark and it's serious it's
amazing all right so I think people are
now anxiously want to know like what
wedding can we play the game it will be
holiday of next year 2019 not this year
so sorry to - any hope but now that we
know we can set expectations we're all
gonna be you amped up and hopefully
we'll hear from more from you maybe and
maybe next year
oh yeah well Vince it was great to see
you thanks for stopping by the show
today we do have a little bit more news
on Star Wars so I'm gonna toss it over
to Dennis
[Applause]
[Music]